[Música]
eu pensei rabisquei criou os versos
souto só que não
escrevo tudo de novo imagine se essa tal
fim
eu amo você
[Música]
são palavras repetidas
o sumiu com soro reunidas de movida
de novo mas sim
tal fim
[Música]
já não sei porquê que se inscreveu
sendo fundando
eu nem sei se foi
é assim
é claro em flores meu amor e sim
minha carta fina pra depois e os mil
casos
[Música]
milo dias sempre dizem mar
é uma escolha
que definam amor
[Música]
entre notas a harmonia
acho sempre symphony desafio do percutor
acorde mudança mas no início não não vão
longe de perder
eu não vou a cantarolar pedindo
as utis em travar a compor esta casa mas
o início
i
hum
já não sei porque quem se inscrever
e não sou nem precisei
se fui
[Música]
levarem flores meu amor e fim
minha casa fica pra depois
[Música]
eu não eu
eu tinha sempre disse
ae não há escolha
há quem defina o amor
an a
[Música]
hum
o
obrigada obrigada ninguém saiba que hoje
do mesmo jeito que entrou né ea música
pesada ela não ser um toque propriamente
dita
ela tem seu papel ela tenha seu encaixe
no evento como esse
a música é uma ferramenta extraordinária
pra gente se conectar se concentrar e
levar nossa vibração aqui e é o nosso
estímulo primário de hoje em a música
para que a gente consiga já entrar no
clima e absorver da melhor forma
possível tudo o que a gente ouve é das
histórias compartilhadas nas inspirações
dos insights que com certeza a gente vai
ter que hoje a nossa próxima música ela
se chama maternal
[Música]
e que chegou
mas onde por amor
que transbordam de mim e se espalhou na
casa
instalou
ele fosse seu lugar me trouxe o
hakim estradão
é isso
2 quando tv foi como
hero segundos sem mais sem pressa pra
respirar
[Música]
quem não quer
o menino que pinta só se sente em
segredo
o que tá com medo de não ser capaz e d
[Música]
desde que chegou do mar mais nada no
núcleo
eu cheiro do sangue
espalha pela taça
ei-lo ganha vai despertar em mim o
melhor
eu quero disse lula
pode soltar minha mão e 12 quando teve
foi como perder lá
[Música]
ficou 25 anos sem pressa pra se inspirar
a final que é amor que não sei
pita só se sente e ímpar
[Música]
o grito que tá com medo de não ser capaz
a minha mãe
sei que tem medo de não vir
dói perder nem doeu
eu entendi que nada mais
e para que encontrou
[Música]
muito obrigada é ea nossa última música
ela foi feita inspirada na ideia de como
a gente às vezes se perde de alguém é
passa o tempo a gente se perde de alguém
muito especial muito único muito
importante e como que a gente reconhece
essa pessoa perdida depois de muito
tempo muitos anos sem se ver sem se
encontrar ea gente se vê de novo como
que a gente reconhece e isso vale das
vezes não só para essa vida né pode ser
quem sabe para outras vidas então o nome
dessa música reencontro
[Música]
será que vou sentir
será que vou saber de reconhecer não
será fácil será na multidão
o naf lado olhando pra você assim o anã
[Música]
você virar que pai lhe vai faltar
sinto que vou lembrar que o cheiro meus
olhos seu cabelo porque dica vale citar
que que vai se lembrar de mim
[Música]
que será assim
hum
é de ficar
[Música]
saudade de nem sei dizer
será que consentir hiroki lusa
reconhecer ser a face na fila
olhando pra você
você irá que pele na exacta e tanque vai
ficar se o cheiro
em seus olhos seu cabelo
que dica vai cantar e que vai se lembrar
o primeiro
[Música]
enquanto eu não penso que mais não quero
que no ska e te guarde pra mim
enquanto isso pensa pra te lembrar que
eu quero te montar que a vida não tem
fim
eu acho
o esperado
assim
[Música]
i
i defende
o de chegar mais perto
[Aplausos]
conforto e paz no seu antebraço
ocupa que o seu espaço
a casa é sua
dra
a cabeça boa pode tratar
[Música]
[Risadas]